oh yeah I fell asleep one second Conan
now we may begin
congratulate you because I didn't know
what to expect when I saw the Three
Stooges movie I went with a bunch of
people from the office and we laughed
our asses off oh you were very funny and
thank you that you've been well you guys
really do a fantastic job thank you very
very much I had thank you no we're not
clapping for the Hunger Games no I have
a bunch of friends that that that saw it
and they were very supportive but I
actually had this one friend who is
addicted to texting his guy Jeffery and
he constantly texted me and then puts
lol after every single thing he texts oh
he doesn't discriminate just no just lol
so like I first of all I kind of find it
funny that he calls himself out on his
own comedy you know but like he what
he'll do the most host and most mundane
things like you know he'll say I'm in
line at the grocery store in the 10
items or less lol and I'm like what's
funny but there's nothing funny about
that yeah and he doesn't realize that
like in a conversation in the real world
texting is just like an extension of a
real conversation so if if he was having
that conversation with me in person it
would sound something like hey I'm
standing in the grocery line at the 10
items are
but that's not very funny or or
interesting or like you know I'm at the
doctor's office waiting for my test
results
but he did say he was at the at the
premiere and there's lots of people I
couldn't find him I said you know I text
him what do you think of the movie and
he said I thought it was hysterical
period so 10 items or less makes cracks
him up laughs out loud yes but no no lol
yeah but did you you must have enjoyed I
mean I was impressed with the with the
the discipline it takes to make this
movie the physical comedy this has got
to be very hard yeah I mean everything
the timing has to be just right the
sound effects were spot-on yes the sound
effects were actually I actually took
the sound effects with me you it like
you know when you do like a TV show or a
movie you could take a souvenir from
when you're done shooting yeah that's
like a memorabilia thing you know I
actually took them with me so I can do
them anytime anywhere I want I don't
know even though it sounds something
like this
[Applause]
yeah that's incredible you just putting
the house wherever you go anywhere I go
if I can't get a table like at a
restaurant where did you shoot this
movie I shot in that Lance I don't know
if you have ever been to Atlanta in the
summer but like you can't even breathe
it's so hot yeah we've been there it's
disgusting
yeah I can tell you you love it as much
as idea well in the summer it's Brut we
did a tour we went there in the summer
and just the it was so humid so hot no
one even left their houses it's
unbelievable I was so I got there at
this hotel it was fantastic hotel the
people were really really nice but I did
the first thing any traveler does which
I use the bathroom right away and I
stopped it up I can't even talk about it
but then I call I called down and I
called down and I answer the phone they
study yes mr. Hayes oh my god hey um so
they write it why the way they know who
you are right yeah so I was like hey I
can't be anonymous no no you can't it's
been like hey do you guys have a you
know do is there like do you have like
there's something that can you know and
they're like yeah sure right away
Richard mr. Hayes needs a plunger right
away God so they send somebody up knock
at the door this gentleman's there with
this bag and the plunger in the back and
he says um you want me to get it I was
like actually it's none of your business
I'm fine getting it so he hands me the
bag and as I'm walking away he turns
around he says I turn around and say you
said what he's just gonna stand there
and wait or and he says yes but by the
way you Sean Hayes and I was like oh
just the embarrassing factor just went
up ten more notches and he literally
said this to me I'm not me it's tough
because oh my god I can't believe I'm
meeting you my girlfriends
[Laughter]